Speaker 1: All right. Let's start with America
Fest 2022 and Carrie Lake's disgusting rant, which
should really serve as a very scary warning to
what is potentially to come if these people figure
out a way to get more power. Now, fortunately,
Kari Lake lost her Arizona gubernatorial election,
and by lost, I mean her opponent, Katie Hobbs,
received more votes. And thus Katie Hobbs will be
governor rather than Carrie Lake. Some people seem
to think that's crazy, but to me it's logical.
Katie Hobbs got more votes. So Katie Hobbs is the
governor coming in rather than Carrie Lake? Carrie
Lake lost so she doesn't get to be the governor.
This is a complicated concept for many of these
right wingers, this rant. And by the way, I don't
think this Carrie Lake stuff, Carrie Lake is still
even though she lost. She ran one election and
she lost. She's still being held up as a hero.
She got one of the prime speaking times at this
America Fest event over the weekend. But I think,
obviously, she's not going to become
the governor, so they're going to stop
interviewing at some point, I think maybe end
up on Fox News or something like that. She.
I don't even know where to start. She
makes an obscene gesture to the media
for being mean to Trump. And one of the funny
things is she makes the gesture to the back of
the room. I'm pretty sure it was only right wing
media covering this thing. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Anybody I know and these
bastards in the media want to drag.
Unidentified: Him through the mud.
Speaker 1:
Okay. And she's making an obscene gesture
right now. And the crowd is cheering.
Yeah. She's pointing to the back of the room.
This is part of the kind of low base politics that
we've covered the American right and increasingly
sliding towards while we on the left want to talk
about, hey, you know what, dental insurance
should be included in health insurance. Why
is it separate or is there a way we can figure
out to make a transition off of fossil fuels for
home heating more affordable for everybody? These
are the types of questions we're concerned with.
This is the stuff that the right is doing,
which is increasingly just being titillating
by swearing or making obscene gestures or making
fun of groups of people, usually minority groups
of people that are disadvantaged or certainly
not in positions of power. Speaking of which,
also now very popular to do sort of a little
light, anti-trans rhetoric no matter what by
stating your pronouns, but then saying something
stupid like Kerry says, My pronouns are I one.
Speaker 3: I know that right now we can identify
as anything we want to. Oh, that's all. But
I want you to know that I identify as
a proud election denying. Deplorable.
Unidentified: Are you with me? Yeah.
Speaker 3:
And my pronouns. Are.
Unidentified: I just saw another
red light go off, by the way.
And my pronouns are I one.
Speaker 1:
She lost her opponent, got more votes. That's
why she's speaking at America Fest rather than
preparing to be the governor of Arizona. So why
is this getting so popular, this anti-trans stuff,
making fun of pronouns? Why is it becoming so
popular among MAGA Trumpists? One reason is that
Trump has shown a tendency to be sort of hostile
to trans rights. He's made statements and taken
actions that are obviously hostile to the trans
community, where he ridicules weightlifters and
swimmers and does his whole routine and talks
about teaching transgender. So the suck ups are
going to follow Trump's lead. That's one reason
why this is going on. Secondly, Trump supporters
have been emboldened to express similar views and
to adopt the same sentiment. It's kind of like the
Kanye anti-Semitism thing, which we talked about
at the top of the show. It has an impact and
they're feeling emboldened and more comfortable
publicly saying they believe this stuff. There's
also probably a belief to some degree that if
you are aligned with Trump ism on the anti-trans
stuff, you're you will be able to mobilize your
base in other ways. And unfortunately, it seems
to be true to some degree. We saw the anti-trans
and homophobic stuff very, very strongly front and
center at CPAC, and it did seem to coalesce and
excite people. And it seems like that's more or
less what continues to go on. So to the extent
that they seem to get a reaction by doing this,
they'll continue the pronoun stuff, even if they
don't actually understand a damn thing about
what's going on in the world of trans and gender
as they clearly don't carry like. Also focusing
her ire on Dr. Fauci and calling him an elf.
Speaker 3: We're not going to answer to
that evil elf, Dr. Fauci, anymore. Wow.
Speaker 1: Are you really powerful to speak out
against a retiring 80 something year old doctor
who spent 50 years helping people? Me on that. How
strong she is.
Unidentified:
Let's walk that man up fast. Lock him up.
Speaker 3: Lock him up. We don't need a big
cell for that guy. Small one will do.
Speaker 1: Are they also making fun of
Foushee? Because he's short. Like, I mean, we're
getting an America fest, making fun of gay people,
trans people and short people, I guess. I mean,
it's all very, very strange. And then one more of
these clips from Kari Lake talking about burning
Maricopa to the ground, I guess, over the election
results that she doesn't like because she lost.
Speaker 3: They are daring us to do something
about it.
Speaker 1:
Right.
Speaker 3: Let me tell
you what I'm going to do. They have built
a house of cards here in Maricopa County.
Speaker 1: Look.
Speaker 3: I think they're
all wondering what I'm going to do. Yeah.
Speaker 1: You're going to do nothing,
Kerry. You lost.
Speaker 3:
I'll tell you what. I'm not just going
to knock that house of cards over.
We're going to burn it to the ground. The.
Speaker 1:
Unclear if she's threatening criminality
there, but this is, at least for now,
someone who's considered exciting, a great
speaker, a great motivator of whatever Maga
Trumpism is. And she's very, very dangerous.
Now, before we move on to other America,
first stuff, I want to look at one
other Kerry Lake event over the weekend.